millions and millions of people voted  for us tonight  and  a very  sad group of people  is trying to disenfranchise that group  of people i got it i got it why don't we  nuke them trump said we drop a bomb  inside the eye of the hurricane and  disrupt it so what are we going to do  here folks i only need 11 000 votes  fellas i need 11 000 votes give me a  break twitter has banned donald trump  permanently from its platform michael  cohen alleges the hush money payments  for which he was convicted for which he  pled guilty were specifically directed  specifically requested of him by donald  trump himself donald trump fired fbi  director james comey north korea  best not make any more threats to the  united states  they will be met  with fire and fury